[Music]
welcome everybody to Lone crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber months after their son
pleaded guilty to committing a school
shooting his parents are next in line
for charges Ethan crumbly killed four
people and injured seven others in 2021.
on Tuesday a Michigan appeals court
heard arguments from both defense
attorneys and the lead prosecutor in the
case against his mother and father
they're trying to decide whether
Jennifer and James crumbly should be
brought to trial on involuntary
manslaughter charges the Michigan
Supreme Court granted the request to
have the case heard by an appellate
court after the couple requested that
the charges be thrown out a decision
hasn't been made on the case yet but if
the Appellate Court rules in favor of
the prosecution Jennifer and James
crumbly will be the first parents in
America to stand trial in connection to
a school shooting during the hearing
appellate judges did not go easy on the
attorneys in this case let's take a
listen
James crumbly had no knowledge of what
EC was planning he was called over to
the school that day was me he was he
acknowledged then
he had knowledge that there was a
drawing but had no knowledge of what EC
was planning to do that day or at any
other point
certainly a warning signal wouldn't you
say
it could be a warning sign that he
but not a warning sign that he was going
to kill for other people
go ahead sorry warning sign that maybe
he had access to a gun
James crumbly did not know that EC had
access to that firearm he bought him
because
well and the first thing he did when he
heard about the school shooting was go
back home to see if the gun was there
so certainly was on the top of his head
the school district or the personnel
there equally is culpable so as the
parents as Ms Smith said I would I would
push back on that and say no first I
would disagree that they had the same
level of knowledge these parents knew
more such as he was gifted that gun days
earlier that it was considered his that
he was having a Gun there's nothing
illegal for parents buying a gun for
their children there's not but it is the
school district even said it's a it's a
fine hobby it is don't bring it to
school it is you also charged EC as an
adult
should that factor in you consider him
as an adult the white or the Oakland
County prosecutor's office the state
considers him an adult
should that factor in our decision here
no he's not he's not a child you're
calling him an adult
all right I'm joined right now by my
co-hosts and legal analyst defense
attorney Brian buckmeyer and former
trial Attorney Terry Austin Terry the
judges that's both sides some pretty
difficult questions who do you think had
the better argument
made a great case but the defense
about it and those
those very difficult the judge wanted to
know all of the judges actually were
asking about whether or not it was
foreseeable was there a duty owed to the
other students was the action or
inaction of the parents the proximate
cause of the death of the students and
so they really wanted to get to the
roots into the bottom line to determine
whether or not these parents because
this is the issue can these be parents
held criminally liable for the criminal
actions of their son and as it turns out
the facts in this case are egregious and
that's what the prosecution was trying
to argue they were saying that there was
so much information that they should
have known that their child was going
through these depressions and had
hallucinations there were text messages
to the mother about the hallucinations
he lost his dog his best friend moved
away all of those factors I think are
what makes the prosecution's case pretty
strong Brian why is the case being heard
by appellate courts why is it on appeal
and by the way the decision here do you
think it could have bigger repercussions
are up down the line yeah so Jesse
typically we see appeals after someone's
been convicted but here the fundamental
question of whether or not the actions
of the parents falling in line with the
charge that they're facing that being
involuntary manslaughter that's only a
pellet Court's going to jump into before
a trial court gets a first bite at the
Apple so to speak and yes it has massive
repercussions no other states whether it
be a trial court or an appellate court
like we have here has looked at it and
the way the country is built it has 12
circuit courts this is the sixth circuit
court that means that Kentucky Ohio
Michigan and Tennessee those states are
going to be looking to see what Michigan
does and the other states in the rest of
the country are probably doing the same
as well to say where will this line be
drawn right and I think you have to look
specifically at the facts of this case
there are certain elements of it that
might just make it stand out from
anything else when you have people say
that oh it's just going to be a slippery
slope parents will be charged for
everything maybe not so maybe not so
clear
thank you
over the past five months several people
from the United States took trips to
Mexico and never came home the latest
incident was just last week when four
Americans drove from South Carolina to
Mexico looking to get cosmetic surgery
this was according to Mexican officials
and during that trip they found
themselves in the midst of a deadly
shootout and were eventually kidnapped
and thrown in the back of a pickup truck
by heavily armed men all four Americans
were located this week but sadly two of
them didn't make it out alive the
deceased victims have been identified as
Shaheed Woodard and zendell brown the
surviving victims Latavia McGee and Eric
Williams have returned to the United
States and are getting treatment at a
hospital while the investigation's still
ongoing authorities say the victims were
targeted by a Mexican cartel who likely
mistook them for drug smugglers we've
also seen the following uh ongoing
investigation into the death of
Shangrila Robinsons is the woman beaten
to death in October while on vacation in
Cabo San Lucas the 25 year old was found
dead in a hotel room while at a luxury
resort with her friends the group
claimed that Robinson died of alcohol
poisoning but autopsy reports determined
that Robinson in fact had traumed her
head and spine Mexican authorities
issued an arrest warrant in November for
femicide this is a form of gender-based
violence according to a Mexican
prosecutor quote a friend of Robinsons
is the direct aggressor Robinson's
family believes that that person is most
likely back in the United States they're
asking the U.S justice department to get
involved and prosecute her killer and in
a third incident California lawyer
Elliot Blair was found dead in a Mexican
resort in January and they've been
conflicting reports about what exactly
happened you see Blair was in Mexico
with his wife to celebrate their first
wedding anniversary his wife said that
hours before his death they were stopped
by Mexican police for allegedly running
a stop sign the officers demanded cash
and Blair sternly made it clear that the
couple were defense attorneys even
flashing his badge the officers
reportedly asked what hotel they were
staying in took 160 dollars of cash from
them and then ultimately left
authorities initially blamed Blair's
death on an accidental fall since he was
found directly below his second floor
hotel room but an autopsy report by a
Mexican coroner indicated that his death
was an aggravated homicide this week I
actually had a chance to interview two
DEA agents that were involved in the
apprehension of one of the most
notorious drug cartel operators Pablo
Escobar
they control what's going on down there
I'm sure that the Mexican police and
Mexican military will respond but I'm
not sure is as urgently as maybe we
would here in the United States I mean
we've seen that most times they are
outgunned they're overpowered by the
Weaponry that the bad guys have
um the fact that the United States is
working with Mexico I'd love to hear
that
um
little hesitant to believe that 100
because we know that uh president Lopez
obrador is somewhat reluctant to take on
the uh the criminal groups there
especially the drug cartels
Terry it seems that these cases would
have a better chance of being resolved
if they were handled in the United
States would I be right about that I
absolutely believe you are right about
that look you have to look at this from
the perspective of what happens before
the case goes to trial and what happens
once they have the individual in jail
the United States is not perfect the
criminal justice system really has a bad
reputation for having so many people
incarcerated and there are and
predominantly people of color in the
jails in the United States but at least
you have due process and at least some
of those cases are investigated about 50
percent of the cases of the murder cases
are actually resolved in Mexico you
don't have that only about five percent
are resolved and there is torture and
they're killing of defendants so it's
very different and Brian what are some
of the hurdles to prosecute these cases
well Jesse in these cases there's a
little bit different from one to the
other I mean in the tranquila case if
you look at that the perpetrator is
Accused to be an American citizen so
America kind of has the ball on their
court so to speak where they can return
the person back to Mexico and then let
the justice system continue to there but
the question is is this system one
that's going to find Justice Terry's
already pointed out the some of the
shortcomings of the Mexican justice
system but in the other two where it's
alleged drug cartel and it seems like
there's some shady doings on the on the
police department there in the
attorney's case that's a little bit more
difficult because they're the defendant
in the case would be a Mexican citizen
so the U.S can pressure but they can't
really step in and do much from a legal
standpoint in terms of making sure
Justice is found in all three of these
cases just a really sad series of events
for people that were done went down
there